-My first guest tonight is
an Emmy-winning comedian
who you know
from "Saturday Night Live,"
which is all new this week
with host Dave Chappelle
and musical guest --
[ Cheering ]
musical guest Foo Fighters.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Come on!
You can also see him
in the movie "Hubie Halloween,"
which is so funny, man.
He's great.
It's available now on Netflix.
Everyone, please welcome
Kenan Thompson.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ We love Kenan Thompson ♪
♪♪
♪ Saturday Night, SNL ♪
♪ We love Kenan Thompson ♪
♪ He got soul
hear to tell ♪
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-We don't play
entrance music anymore.
That is all new.
What was that?
♪ Kenan Thompson ♪
-Made it up.
-Just made up the song.
-[ Vocalizing ]
-♪ Kenan Thompson ♪
-[ Both vocalizing ]
-Musicians, man.
-I know.
-You guys are the best, man.
Shout out to Philly,
by the way.
You know what I'm talking about?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-You know, Kenan does the
warm-up before the audience --
before the show starts on
"Saturday Night Live."
And it's right up to
the last second.
Usually do standup or you
do a song with the band.
Or I did -- I used to do
Rolling Stones
when I was on the show.
-Which song?
-I did "Midnight Rambler."
-Which goes?
-No, no, no, no, I can't.
That's too much money.
-Is that really?
-We can't afford Rolling Stones.
-Can't even just replay the --
-No.
We can do like a different
version of the song.
-That's amazing.
But, yeah, no, we warm up
the crowd before the show.
And Michael Che does some
good stand-up
and he introduces me
and I force karaoke upon --
upon the crowd.
But it's a good time.
You know, it's good to
get the energy up.
And I get my little jitters out
from seeing people staring at me
and stuff like that.
-Get your nerves out.
I remember I did --
I worked -- I did such --
I really went for
this song so hard.
And I was pretending I was
Mick Jagger --
-You were playing.
-And Keith Richards.
I was playing the guitar
and singing,
then I laid on the ground.
I flipped --
You know, this is pro-COVID.
I was laying on people.
-This is before the show
even starts?
-Before the show even started.
And then I was in a sketch,
the cold open sketch.
-Yeah, yeah.
-And so they go,
"We're starting in, you know,
five seconds."
You know? And you go --
-Voice blown.
-Yup.
-My voice is blown every week.
-Sweaty.
-Yeah.
-Dude, I was in --
Tina was like,
"What is wrong with you?"
I go --
[ Panting ]
-"And live from New York --"
[ Laughter ]
-"Hold on a second.
Rachel, you say it.
You say it. I can't talk."
-It's intense.
But, I mean -- but, you know,
it's a specific kind of love
you have for entertaining,
I think, you know?
-Yeah.
-And that comes through
when you're, I guess,
chosen to be in that role
of even warming up the audience
before we do an awesome show.
-Yeah. 'Cause it's like --
"Yeah, we want this show
to be -- we're a team."
-Yeah, man.
-We want everyone to score.
-I want everybody to experience
a good time, you know?
-Yeah.
-I wish it could be always --
-And this week --
-Shout out to those talented
people that we just saw.
That was -- that was incredible.
-Yeah.
That was amazing, right?
[ Applause ]
-Incredible.
-Isn't that cool?
-All three of them
were very -- I thought it was
funny how she stubbed her toe
a little less
after that first one.
[ Laughter ]
-She got a little bit too real.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's like, "Ooh,
that was a really --"
Yeah, method actor.
-Yeah. That was incredible.
And all the way from Italy.
Come on.
The global unite.
-You have Dave Chappelle
hosting this Saturday.
-Whew!
-First of all, it's the sixth--
Yeah, I mean, come on.
[ Applause ]
But a six-show run
is pretty amazing,
and to end it with
Dave Chappelle who's just,
I mean, brilliant.
-Come on. I mean, who better?
You know what I'm saying?
Especially since
it's a resurgence
of the last four year
when he made his appearance.
You know what I mean?
-Was that four years?
-Yeah.
-Geez.
-And it was, you know,
just an electric week then.
So I know the show Saturday
is going to be powerful.
It's going to be very,
very powerful.
So -- I'm going to be honest.
He complimented us yesterday.
He made an insane speech, you
know, before the table read.
Did the same thing years ago.
But I mean, the guy is just such
a prolific speaker.
You know what I'm saying?
And he speaks from the heart,
and a brilliant mind.
And it's such a pleasure
to be around.
I mean, y'all know.
-Yeah.
Yeah, you went to his thing
in -- in Ohio, right?
-That's right.
-That's -- he's just -- I --
he's like a -- beyond --
I don't want to say wordsmith,
it's beyond that.
He's a poet. He's like --
it's so many things.
But funny.
Dude, I remember back in the day
when we --
I used to do stand-up
and see him.
This is when -- does he still
smoke on stage?
-Constantly.
-Yeah.
-He smoked more than
I've ever seen,
and he was like -- and just
lighting up the whole thing.
And this was like --
I don't know what --
I guess if they banned
cigarettes,
that have a weird scene.
-Yeah.
He almost does it on purpose,
I feel like now.
-Exactly, yeah.
Keith Richards was here, and he
smoked and the alarms went off.
-Yeah.
-And I went into
his dressing room.
-"Isn't this this cool?"
-Yeah. No, I said to him,
I go, "Keith, you know
you can't smoke."
He goes, "I know, it's bad
for your health, right?"
[ Laughter ]
He knows what's up.
It's Keith Richards, man.
-He's fine. He'll be fine.
-Can you -- look at this.
That's you --
-Look at that.
-Tracy Morgan, Eddie Murphy,
Chris rock, Dave Chappelle.
What was this feeling like?
-First of all, it was
the Christmas show,
so Merry Christmas to me.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-Those guys --
those are four legends
I'm standing next to.
You know what I'm saying?
You know, going down the line,
Tracy is my brother, you know.
He was the first person
to embrace me,
because I came in
right when he left.
You know what I'm saying?
-That's right.
-He took me to T.G.I. Friday's
for lunch.
Like, "Let's go to Friday's."
[ Laughter ]
-Dude, that sounds real.
-It was very real.
-The one right down the street?
-Yeah, in his Cadillac
Escalade pickup truck.
[ Laughter ]
He pulled it out of the garage
on 48th Street.
-I love him.
-We drove around --
-50th to --
-You could walk --
-Back to 48th and Fifth.
-You could walk to it.
[ Laughter ]
-Just because he wanted us
to see his ride
and he wanted...
-Yeah.
-...to flex on
two and a half blocks.
I always felt him for that.
-That's actually legendary.
-Stepping up.
-You could throw a rock and hit
T.G.I. Friday's
from our building.
-Exactly.
Next to him, you have the
legendary Dave Chappelle, man,
who yesterday told me that
I was good at my job,
and I almost cried,
you know what I'm saying?
Like...
-Seriously?
-The dude is -- I mean, as far
as the pinnacle of people
I look up to in the voice of
my generation, it's that guy.
You know?
And next to him,
the legendary Eddie Murphy, man,
the first black movie superstar,
you know?
And just the first person
that meant everything
to every single person
in my family.
You know what I'm saying?
Everything he did, we all,
like, laughed really hard
and embraced.
You know what I'm saying?
-Of course.
-So next to him,
you have Chris Rock,
who is brilliant
in his own lane.
He carved a lane so strong
that I don't think anybody
can say he's not
probably the greatest --
probably stand-up specials
that HBO ever had.
You know what I'm saying?
-Ever.
-That whole run that he did is
so solid and still --
-Changed the game.
-Brilliant in his mind.
He's killing it on "Fargo"
right now.
You know what I'm saying?
-Yeah, he is, by the way.
-So I could run down the credits
of those dudes all day long.
And shout-out to Michael Che
for even writing me
in that moment, man.
Like, I'm just -- like,
I'm floored when I see it.
-And how about the person
holding this picture?
[ Laughter ]
-And the -- and --
-That's --
-If you zoom in
on the pink knuckles around --
[ Laughter ]
They belong to --
-Zoom in on the pink knuckles.
-They belong to my brother
James Fallon, who...
[ Laughter ]
...is probably one of
the funniest people
I've ever been around
in my entire life.
-Thank you.
That's all I wanted, yeah.
-Yeah, absolutely, hands down.
-Thank you, I appreciate that.